vous je vais m'occuper de vous juste
avant qu'il reprenne
je posais une question parce que les
téléspectateurs doivent savoir la
semaine dernière on a fait le break dès
9 ans a et on a eu une grande surprise à
quelqu'un qui aime la castagne
oui c'est vrai quelqu'un qui avait cité
in the tender vidéo soit ils avaient
envie de tomber amoureux
jean claude van damme qui a eu un crush
couvrir ses passes étaient au courant
dit oui parce que tu es très copines
coin de gesca sache que jean claude van
damme est un gros gros crush pour
francesca je sais que le sari alors reçu
sa petite valérie que tu le dis
francesca mandat c'est vrai que ça sonne
bien
jusqu'à quand même ça sonne bien alors
francesca j'ai vu des photos circulent
et de vous au restaurant puisqu'on me
les envoyer avec van damme
oui non non juré alors est-ce que je
vous savez que tout me revient
vous étiez au reste on ne l'a pas dit
sais-tu au restaurant avec jean claude
van damme
non non c'était vendredi soir
vraiment pas on avait dit que j'aurai du
temps pour répondre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ma nature
c'est pas cette question qu'il faudra
répond j'aurais du temps pour répondre à
la deuxième question pour le moment
est ce que vous étiez au restaurant avec
jean claude van damme ainsi qu'un autre
couple
plus son manager vous étiez je crois 6
ou 7 à table c'est sa secte
oui ou non non mais c'est pas comme ça
c'était le nom oui bon moment on s'est
retrouvé comme ça oui comme tu veux
j'étais cette année-là il noté alors
dans ben alors oui ou non on était là
oui à un moment tu as toi non pages il a
eu l'info également on allait mais c'est
les mecs je dis sans le milieu de la
night 7 heures et ce n'était 23h22 oui
bah c'est la nike au bout alors meoli
nous vrai ou pas oui un moment c'est bon
reçoit reste que tout ce que je veux
savoir
la deuxième question vous l'imaginez
vous répondez pas d'une question est
simple est-ce qu'il n'a pas levé que la
jambe
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les mauves est la question est quel
jamila levrat aussi merci
non vous pouvez me dire non mais on ne
répondra pas à cette question a placé la
vie privée c'est comme si je vous
demandais sefa tout l été ou là où vous
voulez aller là bas parce que moi je
sais qui et je sais que mon meilleur
pote la voix tous les soirs pendant
l'émission donc c'est bon les prénoms
noms mais le réveil ne répondait pas
abbassi non non pas tout de suite
maintenant
pas comme ça pas vous